this is a production of Cornell
University
our next presenter is Aaron we break my
Aaron's from Gettysburg Pennsylvania and
he was mentored on this project by Mike
Gore with healthcare undergraduate James
Chalmers and after graduation he plans
to an intern at civic mix with us the
seminar title is filled in affecting 3G
once again my name is Aaron way bright I
am a senior plant science major
graduating this in a few weeks now and
concentrating in plant breeding and
genetics so the project I was working on
with the gore lab yep I took I got
inspired to just work in the gore lab by
taking Michael Gord octor Michael Gore's
class nutritional quality improvement of
field crops most of my exposure to clamp
reading thus far had been to maximize
traits that maximize yield and the
approach they were taking was to work on
traits that increase the nutritional
quality of it so it's kind of difficult
because they're not as easily quantified
but ultimately they're resulting in
higher quality crops which i think is
something that's very important so I
signed on for it as a field assistant
the following the following summer and
stayed on with the lab to continue
working with the data I collected over
the summer in a fall research project so
most of the work was done at Aurora
where a member of the gore lab Matmos a
geo PhD student is working on a breeding
project this was the third year of the
breeding project to increase vitamin A
and E content and sweet corn adapted for
the New York environment so I was
spending most of the time working on
that a little bit of time working with
the field corn for another project but I
was gaining a lot of exposure to
phenotyping tools so as breeding
projects become you know more expansive
and as the technology really increases a
lot we had the capability to collect
simply a ton of data now which key no
can only can only lead to better results
so I spent the majority of my time
working with this phenotyping we had a
mobile field book app which was you know
a little just a smartphone app and we
had barcodes and scanners we were using
to collect our phenotypic data
so this was a really made it much easier
back that than back to the days when you
had to you know use your ruler and write
down your measurements so we took things
such as flowering time plant height ear
height node council etc plant height is
the trait that most relevant to the rest
of this talk so we've collected all of
this data over the summer and I was
still really interested in I asked stay
one in the fall to work with this data
to help me involved in this breeding
project and I was advised by James
Hammes someone who recently graduated
was also working in the gore lab I
wasn't I've been learning a lot about
genetics in school but I was finding now
that at the aforementioned large big
datasets I really had to learn a lot
about computers so James was very
invaluable in this and I was
particularly relevant for organizing the
data after I had the data organized I
had to perform calculations which I will
we'll get more into later and then the
final ultimate step G loss here which I
will also explain in more detail so this
here is an example of what the data kind
of looks like after it's coming through
the mobile field book app so it's just
kind of who collected this data some
some metadata is in the metadata is the
data about the data so like this is when
it was collected the trait and then you
kind of got this here the barcode number
for the plant and the other relevance
here the relevant measurements as you
can tell it's kind of messy it's not a
not really particularly useful not not
easily easily analyzed for for a
breeding project so this was the end
result took me took me a lot of time to
learn computer programming to process
all of this instead of sorting it by
hand so you know this is nice and
organized we've got the field terms here
you know and then then the height
measurement there so I did most of this
through Python which was actually pretty
easily accessible I learned a lot of it
through the C yet computer science notes
I never took the course but all the
notes are freely available through the
glass so that was definitely a big help
and I learned a lot of computer skills
here you know how to
process these these large large data
sets that you could what take you years
and years and then a two months too much
time to process by hand so one thing I
really encountered and this is something
that I really learned a lot about in in
a field trial here so oftentimes the
data is not perfect so right here one of
the example was a you know should be
obvious to large just like just okay is
that data good wrong tool use that's
concerning bar code was upside down also
concerning so I had to go back through
and check to make sure that this data
was actually usable and then you know
adding the the necessary Corrections so
the next step after all the data was in
an organized will form was to perform
Bluff calculations so the sweet corn
diversity panel we had planted out a
bunch of different genotypes to see how
they perform in the New York environment
then you know we could choose from those
for the breeding program as it
progresses but a field trials there they
got a lot going on so like one portion
of the field was like just riddled with
corn rootworm if you guys remember over
the summer there was a really big
drought so like it's not these perfect
numbers the perfect values for what the
value of this plants genotype so the
bluff calculation uses a mixed model so
multiple variables considers multiple
variables in terms to get a standardized
value so like it takes in all this field
terms I mentioned and kind of it kind of
works that out so it uh it makes a blob
stands for best linear unbiased
prediction so like you know if we can
remove the biases from like the drought
and from the corn rootworm hopefully we
can get the true value of this genotype
and then we can actually consider it for
the breeding program the bluff wrapper
which is a program we used in our
statistical analysis software considers
all of these terms for significance and
decides to see which ones are impacting
it and then adjust the value that the
that the bluff value for that genotype
accordingly and then the REM will is
also part of this to reach this this
true value it gives so to understand it
puts weights on like field terms like
the the field organizational statistics
or the field yet
and gives you like the necessary weights
to give it true a true value of what
your what the genotypes you're
considering so after we had I kind of
got a good grasp on this we were going
to do some height trait analysis this
was we chose this because it was my
first time working working with this
type of bioinformatics process so this
is to be a pretty straightforward trait
you know wouldn't wouldn't be would it
be too too difficult to assess so we
decided to move forward with that so I
had to learn a little bit more computer
skills to process this data so here is
is the result of the blocks so this
straight line here would be like you
know a truly a truly standardized line
these little dots here are the genotype
values so if it was a perfect fit all of
the little dots will be on the line that
is you can see we've got some trailing
off here at the top and trailing off at
the bottom meaning that even you know
even with the all the statistical
information we put in there we were
still not able to get good values for
these genotypes good estimates of what
their Worth was but fortunately because
I came in later after three years of the
breeding project existing I was able to
draw upon 2014 and 2015 data to to
bolster the strength to this analysis so
here are the model terms so like you
know genotype year super these those are
filled terms and the program considers
those you know two feet to see which
ones are impacting it and we got a much
better fit here a little bit of trailing
off but that's expected so we could we
could a we could work with these values
so now we had a good understanding of
what these each one of these genotypes
was words so now we decided to move on
to Jia Jia stands for genomic wide
Association study so all the genotypes
we were working with are you know pretty
well studies pretty well mapped plenty
of snips which are single nucleotide
polymorphisms which represent like a
known location in a genome that yeah we
can scan for and tag that very quickly
so we were testing for the relevancy of
these snips for plant height so
you know a bunch of the really tall
plants had all had the same snips like
it seems like likely that those nips are
linked genes that are influencing plant
height so we tested the stiffs relevant
to here each blue dot their counselor
the snip and if they were high above the
red line that indicates relevancy and as
you see this was kind of surprising most
of them were high above the red line but
because most modern maize breeding is do
you cross these lines back and forth
there's a lot of relatedness which could
make snips seem more relevant than they
actually are so we connect corrected for
this kinship and we got this resulting
graph and all the snips here are right
along the blue line are right along the
red line which which actually indicates
that there were no significant no
significant snips in influencing plant
height this is a Manhattan plot each one
of these different colored portions is a
chromosome and the height of the dot
height of the snip indicates the
relevancy of this to plant height and
they would have to be much higher for
for a relevant result or a relevant hit
so this was kind of disappointing but
ultimately not super surprising because
plant height is a very quantitative
trait meaning that there are many many
many small genes each influencing the
ultimate result of the plant height so
we were not able to identify any
particular genes that were having a
major impact so once again no
significant results which was kind of
disappointing but gave me a big a big a
nice look into how science is done and
this is how oftentimes the results of
these projects so I got a real real feel
for how is how what's this got going on
but it was really good for me to gain
experience and you know in how a
breeding project is actually conducted
like I can only you know don't we get
such a feel for it from from learning
through the classroom like the field
study was definitely surprised we really
had to encounter a lot of a lot of
obstacles and things that would change
our data and keep it from being like the
perfect green house trial experiment
that's obviously not achievable in a few
study the data organization I think was
really important to learn because
computer programming and big data big
bioinformatics is only going to be more
relevant in the breeding field moving
forward and I was able to be involved in
this analysis which is which was a you
know helping to decide the value of
these genotypes and I look forward to
learning more about possibly into grad
school how to select from that analysis
what what genotypes you want to work
with moving forward and yeah
bioinformatics very important I like to
give acknowledgments to these members of
the gore lab dr. Michael Gore for taking
me on and giving you the opportunity to
work in his lab with his with his
facilities James Chambliss for advising
me throughout the project Nick asmar the
lab advisor for also continuing to
supply a lot of advice and helping me
work through problems map pistachio this
was his project after all so of course
after thank him and dr. LD Quezada for
providing the bluff wrapper for the
statistical analysis any questions I was
unclear what made the analysis by Olivia
model this is the overview talking this
one here okay so whatever you're shown
the model goes a couple of this here huh
the otherwise with this so you set it up
copy on BIOS prediction what makes it on
by if I'm not clear so ok so if we
planted the planted the genotypes it's
not a normal linear model because it's
considering multiple factors here like
the fixed effects and the random effects
so that is what make it a different than
a linear model if I'm answering your
question
so I would understand - in figures you
have a decimal in your position and you
have a sesame on five addition some
could ask what my connection is
definitely on five that makes that would
I buy it
Shilla oh yeah so the the unbiased
portion takes out the the field study
bias so for example part of the field
that we planted out and had a corn worm
corn rootworm and if we were to not
correct for that we would just think
there's genotypes for crap when really
they might be valuable but uh they just
had the unfortunate luck of being
planted in a blighted portion of the
field so this helps to correct for that
some of them block yeah it utilizes the
field blocking the utilizes of the field
blocking terms you go about two more
slides forward again sure thing so can
you explain to what the basis of that is
and how we do the corrections just tell
me about steamships it was okay yeah so
because a lot of these genotypes had
been you know had lineages exchanged and
they're in their history and the arrival
to this final product they are all
related to some degree and we're all
sharing some of the snips to some degree
and so this was making snips seem more
relevant than they actually were so we
included a kinship matrix which helps
tone down the relevancy based on how
related the two genotypes the genotypes
were to each other the diversity and
supposed to a limited extent another to
know
I'm shocked if there's that much
relationship so because we were were
planting out maize lines we planted out
maize lines that were expected to grow
you know fairly well in this climate
that so that you know those types of
made lines probably had similar similar
backgrounds and ancestry to result you
know and it's the same climate
adaptiveness
yeah good one that was fun I wouldn't be
a normally distributed or not what
relevance does that have to do with
whether models accurate are just a
little bit unclear okay so we didn't
expect any of these genius types to be
like rockstars like we they were all
kind of similar so like if one of them
was suddenly so much better than all of
the other ones like that would be an
issue so we wanted a nice distribution
of seeing how they perform so which
which was was the straight line there
and so like after after we correct
unbiased the the results we were able to
get a nice distribution along that line
that's if I'm answering a question this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu